en este vídeo vamos a modificar la
estructura exterior de nuestra beats y
voz para que los interruptores quepan y
puedan quedar en su lugar no estoy muy
segura de cuánto material debemos quitar
vamos a quitar un pedazo y veremos qué
tal queda al hacer esto me di cuenta de
que no es bueno usar las pinzas de corte
en este material ya que hace que el
plástico tiende a romperse en lugares
donde no queremos que se rompa así que
es mejor usar el cúter y quitar un
pedazo cada vez hasta llegar al tamaño
que queremos recuerden que siempre deben
ser cuidadosos al usar navajas o
cuchillos asegúrense de usar lentes de
seguridad especialmente cuando usen un
cúter como este en el que las secciones
se pueden desprender y caernos en los
ojos aquí pueden ver que el plástico se
corta muy fácilmente con el cúter
quitamos el plástico suficiente para que
deje libres a nuestros interruptores
vamos a quitar un poco más de plástico
pero de una manera que sea agradable
estéticamente en lugar de tener bordes
bruscos haremos curvas suaves y así
dejaremos espacio suficiente para
nuestros cables verdes marcamos el
contorno con nuestro cúter y cortamos
pedazos más grandes con nuestra pinza de
corte pero no mucho porque quartet a
nuestro plástico y ya el corte más fino
lo hacemos con nuestro cúter finalmente
nos aseguramos de que la estructura
exterior deje libres a los interruptores
y a los cables verdes eliminando el
material extra lo volteamos para
asegurarnos de que todo luce bien
después suavizamos los bordes ahora lo
alineamos por última vez y colocamos los
tornillos que sostienen esta estructura
exterior en su lugar con esto terminamos
las modificaciones de la estructura
externa hacemos los últimos ajustes a
los cables verdes de calibre 12 y nos
aseguramos de que queden bien
en sujetos en su lugar al igual que los
interruptores ya hemos cargado código en
él arduino y ahora vamos a golpear
levemente los interruptores para ver si
se encienden las luces así lo hace y
vemos que las luces funcionan bien y que
nuestros interruptores de defensa cubren
casi todo el frente y la parte de atrás
para asegurarnos de que cuando golpeamos
una pared nos podamos alejar de ella